being a business is
part of their is in their own part of
the american dream
i have every confidence that under miss
guzman's leadership
the sba will help small business owners
hold on to their dreams
until our economy comes roaring back
this morning i also want to continue the
theme of highlighting aspects of the
american rescue plan that have not
received enough attention
we've heard a lot about the progress
that we've made on vaccines
i read this morning that 109 million
americans have received at least one
vaccination
so we are well on the path well on the
path
to getting americans vaccinated and
checks have gone out the door i was on a
call with people
from central brooklyn bed-stuy in
brownsville last night and many had
already received their checks
very much needed very much welcomed as
president biden announced today on these
on the vaccines we've had a hundred
million shots in people's arms
and a hundred million checks in people's
pockets
let's say that again that sounds good to
me mr president
a hundred million shots in people's arms
and a hundred million checks in people's
pockets democrats are delivering what we
promised
now we've heard a lot about how the
american rescue plan will help americans
who need it the most the 20 percent of
americans at the lowest levels of income
will receive the highest levels of
support
it's about time we had the mirror image
of that when our republican colleagues
ran the senate
where the top one percent did the best
and the bottom 20 percent were totally
ignored
that's backwards god bless the people
who are in the top one percent
but they don't need the help it's the
people struggling to feed their families
pay the rent help the kids in school
that need the help and we're doing it
first time in a while
experts predict that child poverty could
be cut in half
meanwhile the top one percent of
americans will see an income boost
of zero percent as i said god bless them
but they're doing fine already they're
doing fine
already and we've heard a lot about how
the american rescue plan will prime the
american economy to come roaring back
economists are already projecting that
economic growth could double as a result
of the american rescue plan
when over 75 85 i think it is percent of
americans get some checks the money goes
out
it starts revitalizing our economy
people shop in the stores
eat at the restaurants even begin to
travel
see their relatives maybe for the first
time if people are vaccinated
wow this is great news this is great
news
so i think that america
is turning the corner and i think the
attitude of americans is turning the
corner as well people now see a brighter
future
for this country and their regions so
today though as i said there's so much
in this bill but every day i want to
focus on something else that may not be
focused upon
since the senate is set to vote on the
confirmation of the new sba
administrator
today is a good opportunity to expand on
just how the american rescue plan
will help our nation's 30 million small
businesses
now we all know that small businesses
have been some of the hardest hit
entities
by the pandemic early in the crisis
80 percent four out of five of small
businesses
reported having to close their doors at
one point
just the other day just the other day
i heard uh of a local new york business
owner
was forced to close up shop after
surviving most of the pandemic
you could hear the pain in their voice
they poured their entire soul into this
business i know
this hits home for me my dad was a small
businessman
he struggled he had a little
exterminating business
all through my growing years from the
day i was born
till the day i left the house my
brother's sister and i still have vivid
memories mr president
of dad pacing the floor sunday nights at
2am
because he hated going to work monday
morning so many challenges
so much thrown at him and not much he
could do about it
he was wondering how he would actually
provide for his family
now praise god he retired at around 70.
he's now 97 he's been a happy man for
these last 27 years god is good
as you know mr president better than
most of us
but he struggled and so when i hear
about
the anguish of small business people
i'll never forget
i would work there sometimes weekends
summers
and he sent me out to collect checks
from a
landlord who had three or four buildings
smaller buildings and
we had done the exterior my dad's
company had done the exterminating the
guy hadn't paid for six months
and i traveled took me about an hour an
hour and a half on two buses
to go to this man's door i knocked he
opened the door i said you know
i'm chuck schumer the son of abe schumer
century exterminating you owe us six
months we've been doing a good job
exterminating your house
you know what he said to me your dad's a
small businessman
he can't afford a lawyer he can't afford
anything to go after me i'm not paying
the anguish that small business people
face
so we need to help them we need to help
them
and that's one of the many reasons i'm
so proud of the american rescue plan
because it provides tens of billions of
dollars in
support for small businesses that have
suffered during the pandemic
the american rescue plan is nothing
short
of a lifeline for main street businesses
from one end of this country to the
other main street businesses in rural
america main street businesses in
suburban america main street businesses
in urban america and in our inner cities
it's a lifeline
for starters the american rescue plan
provides 30 billion for restaurants and
bars through the restaurants act
which was the first bipartisan amendment
added to the bill sponsored by senator
cinema
and wicker the american rescue plan also
includes more than a billion dollars in
additional support
for our nation's small theaters and
venues
adding to a grant program i helped
create in december called the save our
stages act these independent art venues
restaurants
art venues and places like that are the
hardest hit because that's where people
churches
that's where people gather when they're
not gathering there's no
income whether it be the money they pay
the small business
check they pay at the restaurant or the
money they leave in the collection plate
when they're not there in our religious
institutions
so this is a good thing
the and i want to say one more thing
about save our stage is it not only
includes more money for save our stages
it includes an amendment i authored to
allow venue
owners to apply for aid through save our
stages without losing eligibility for a
traditional small business grant through
the ppp
so that's a change that our arts
institutions our independent venues our
theater should know they can get both
ppp
and save our stages now
these venues the small businesses of
many types the non-profits
they're the lifeblood of our communities
they were the first to close
they'll be the last to open i'm hopeful
that the support we passed in the
american in the american rescue plan
will help our small businesses our
theaters and our music venues
our restaurants to hold on until we can
all gather safely once again
that's not all the american rescue plan
provides fifteen billion
dollars in flexible targeted grants to
help small businesses that have had a
hard time accessing relief over the last
twelve months
including most non-profits and churches
up to ninety percent
minority owned small businesses will
qualify for this funding
closing the racial gap and keeping local
economies from deteriorating further
we invest 10 billion in state local and
tribal small business financing programs
we expand the employee retention tax
credit
so that businesses of any size can more
easily keep their workers on the payroll
because that one doesn't have
a employee number limit and finally
we've bolstered and expanded the popular
paycheck protection program to include
more non-profits including labor and
agricultural organizations who
unfortunately in december
our republican colleagues won't let in
in a nutshell
the american rescue plan provides a
colossal boost
for our nation's small businesses and
we'll make sure that all of them
not just those with the right
connections can access relief
it'll help millions of americans keep
their jobs retain their income support
their families
during this recovery now we know many of
these businesses are not out of the
woods yet
there is still some time until our
country can fully open up until families
can eat inside their favorite restaurant
or colleagues can meet at a bar for a
happy hour
until we can see one of our favorite
favorite performers put on a concert
but we're already seeing signs of hope
as a washington post headline announced
recently
companies are scaling back layoffs
because of the american rescue plan let
me say that again
proudly and happily companies are
scaling back layoffs because of the
american rescue plan
and the senate i assure the american
people
is going to keep working to make sure
that the support for our businesses
remains intact
over the next few months i yield the
floor
and note the absence of a quorum
the clerk will call the roll ms baldwin
mr president the republican leader is
recognized
i have consent to further proceedings on
the quorum call be dispensed with
without objection
mr and today i'd like to begin with a
few quotations
quote the legislative filibuster
is the most important distinction
between the senate
and the house without the 60-vote
threshold for legislation
the senate becomes a majoritarian
institution
just like the house much more subject
to the wins of short-term electoral
change
no senator would like to see that happen
so let's find a way to further protect
the 60-vote rule for legislation
that was the that was the current
democratic leader senator schumer
in april of 2017 less than four years
ago
uh here's another quote mr president
what about the nuclear option doing away
with the filibuster
i can tell you that would be the end of
the senate as it was originally devised
and created going back to our founding
fathers
we have to acknowledge our respect for
the minority and that is what the senate
tries to do
in its competition composition and
in its procedure end quote that was the
assistant democratic leader senator
durbin
in 2018 about three years ago
a few years ago 33 members of the senate
side signed a letter insisting that
quote we preserve existing rules
practices and traditions regarding
legislation
now under pressure from the outside many
of our democratic colleagues
are abandoning their stated principles
as fast as possible
yesterday senator durbin said the
filibuster is not a core principle but
quote
an off-handed clerical suggestion
an offhanded clerical suggestion
and a number of senate democrats are
trying to pressure the senior senators
from west virginia and arizona
to abandon their own very recent
commitments to honor
the central rule of the senate
mr president the framers designed the
senate to require deliberation to force
cooperation
and to ensure that federal laws in our
big diverse country
earn broad enough buy-in to receive the
lasting
consent of the government james madison
said the senate should be
a complicated check against
improper acts of legislation
thomas jefferson said great innovation
should not be forced
on slender majorities senate democrats
parroted all these arguments when they
were the ones benefiting from minority
protection
when president trump pressed republicans
to kill the filibuster
our democrat colleagues cried fell
and when our republican majority stood
on principle and refused to wreck the
rules
our democratic colleagues happily used
the filibuster themselves
in some cases they flat out block
legislation like senator tim scott's
police reform bill
in many other cases democrats did what
minority parties always do
and leverage the existence of the
filibuster to influence must pass
legislation
long before it got to the floor
there's so much emphasis on the most
extreme bills that either party might
pass with a simple majority
people forget that the senate 60-vote
threshold is the only reason
the only reason that any routine must
pass legislation is bipartisan
except during divided government
big funding deals appropriation bills
farm bills highway bills the ndaa
the senate 60 vote threshold backstops
all of it
it's not just about controversial items
it's about everything we do
the senate democrats who are pressuring
our colleagues from arizona and west
virginia to reverse themselves
are not just arguing for some procedural
tweak
not a procedural tweak they're arguing
for a radically
less stable and less consensus-driven
system of government
forget about enduring laws with broad
support nothing in federal law would
ever be settled
does anyone really believe the american
people were voting for an entirely new
system of government
by electing joe biden to the white house
and a 50-50 senate
this is a 50-50 senate there was no
mandate
to completely transform america by the
american people on november 3rd
that may be what a few liberal activists
want
but does anyone believe that millions of
americans
thought that's what they were elected
of course not there's an ironic element
to this whole conversation
some democratic senators seem to imagine
this would be a tidy
trade-off if they could just break the
rules on a razor thin
majority sure it might damage the
institution but then nothing would stand
between them and their entire agenda a
new era of fast-track policy making
but mr president anyone who really knows
the senate knows that's that's not what
would happen
so let me say this very clearly
for all 99 of my colleagues
nobody serving in this chamber can even
begin
can even begin to imagine
what a completely scorched earth senate
would look like none of us
have served one minute in a senate that
was completely
drained of comedy
and consent this is an institution that
requires united's consent to turn the
lights on before noon
to proceed with a garden variety floor
speech
to dispense with the reading of lengthy
legislative text
the schedule committee business to move
even non-controversial nominees at
anything besides
a snail space so mr fred
i want our colleagues to imagine a world
where every
single task every one of them
requires a physical quorum
which by the way the vice president
does not count in determining accord
everything that democrat senates did to
presidents bush and trump everything the
republican senate did to president obama
would be child's play compared to the
disaster
that democrats would create for their
own priorities
if if they break the senate
so this is not a trade-off between
trampling etiquette
but then getting to quickly transform
the country
that's a false choice even the most
basic aspects of our colleagues agenda
the most mundane task
of the biden presidency would actually
be harder
harder not easier
for democrats in a post-nuclear senate
that is 50 50 dead even
if the democrats break the rules to kill
rule 22
on a 50 50 basis then we will use
every other rule to make tens of
millions
of americans voices heard
perhaps the majority would come after
the other rules next
perhaps rule 22 would just be the first
domino of many
until the senate ceased to be distinct
from the house in any respect
this chaos would not open up an express
lane to liberal change
it would not open up an express lane for
the biden presidency to speed into the
history books
the senate would be more like a hundred
car
pileup nothing moving
and then there's a small matter that
majorities are actually
never permanent
the last time a democratic leader was
trying to start a nuclear exchange
i remember offering a warning
i said my colleagues would regret it a
lot sooner than they
thought in just a few years
and a few supreme court vacancies later
many of our democratic colleagues said
publicly
that they did
touching the hot stove again would yield
the same result
but even more dramatic
as soon as republicans wound up back in
the saddle
we wouldn't just erase every liberal
change that hurt the country
we'd strengthen america with all kinds
of conservative policies with
zero zero input from the other side
about this nationwide right to work
for working americans
defunding planned parenthood in
sanctuary cities on day one
a whole new era of domestic energy
production
sweeping new protections for conscience
and the right to life of the unborn
concealed carry reciprocity in all 50
states in the district of columbia
massive hardening of security
on our southern border
we saw during amendment votes just days
ago that some common-sense
republican positions actually enjoy more
support right now
than some of the democratic committee
chairs priorities
and this is with them and the majority
so the pendulum mr president would swing
both ways and it would swing hard
my colleagues and i have refused to kill
the senate
for instant gratification in 2017 and
2018 i was lobbied to do
exactly what democrats wanted to do now
a sitting president leaned on me to do
it
he tweeted about it
what did i do mr president
i said to the president at that time no
i said no repeatedly
because becoming a u.s senator comes
with higher duties than steamrolling any
obstacle
to short-term power i meant it
republicans met it less than two months
ago
two of our democratic colleagues said
they mean it too
if they keep their word
we have a bipartisan majority that can
put principle first
and keep the senate safe
the clerk will call the robe ms baldwin
mr president the majority whip is
recognized
thank you mr president mr president i
ask unanimous consent that the quorum
paul be lifted
without objection mr president last week
i introduced a bill to permanently
repeal the death tax
i've been pushing to repeal the death
tax for a long time because i've seen
the consequences
the tax can have for family farms and
ranches and for family businesses
and i'm proud that we protected a lot of
family farms and businesses three years
ago with the tax cuts and jobs act
by doubling the death tax exemption but
the death tax is still
a big problem first of all the change we
made to the death tax
in the tax cuts and jobs act isn't
permanent
the increased exemption level expires at
the end of 2025.
second democrats always eager to seize
any possible revenue source have
proposed not merely returning the
exemption to its previous level
but reducing it even further and that
would be a big problem
for a lot of family farms and businesses
mr president the death tax is a
fundamentally flawed idea both in theory
and in practice
every american of course has an
obligation to pay taxes to help support
our government but there should be a
limit
to how many times the government can tax
you
and death should not be a taxable
event the money you leave at your death
has already been taxed by the government
at least once which makes the death tax
double taxation as president people who
support the death tax tend to talk as if
the death tax only affects the
fabulously wealthy
but that isn't the case small
medium-sized businesses
family farms and ranches spend a lot of
time and money on estate planning to
avoid being hit by this tax
farmers and ranchers in my state know
that without careful and costly
planning the federal government can come
around after their death demanding a
staggering
40 percent of their taxable estate
and their children won't have the money
to pay without risking the farm or the
ranch
why well farming and ranching is often a
cash poor business
a farmer might technically be worth
several million dollars but the vast
majority of that is land
and farming equipment only a small
fraction of it
is money in the bank the farm bill
reports that over the past 10 years the
value of farmland has increased by
nearly 50 percent it's completely
possible that a farmer's land might have
substantially increased in value over
the past decade while his
income has barely increased at
all or with commodity prices the past
few years and they've been losing money
in fact it's perfectly possible that in
a bad year a farm will sever
with several million dollars worth of
land
might barely break even income wise
so what happens when a farmer dies well
the federal government will claim up to
40 percent
of his taxable estate but his liquid
assets in other words the cash he has
available will likely not come close to
covering the tax bill from the federal
government
and so the only thing left for his
children to do
will be start selling off farm equipment
and land
in some cases they will be able to keep
the farm just a smaller version of it
and others they may have to sell off the
family farm
entirely the same thing can happen with
family owned businesses in the case of a
larger family owned business the
business owner may be worth 15 or 20
million dollars
only a small fraction of that may be
money in the bank
the vast majority may be tied up in the
business
in that case when the federal government
comes around demanding 40 percent of the
taxable estate
all the money that that business owner
had in the bank won't even come close
covering
the tax bill to pay the federal
government the owner's descendants will
have to sell off part or all
of the family business and this can
happen
again and again think about a business
that was started half a century ago and
passed down from father to daughter
to grandson with every death the federal
government
will have will have will have come
demanding
a big chunk of that estate
by the time you get to the third
generation the business may be
struggling to stay afloat
if it's still around at all i recently
read testimony from business owner who
stated that without
death tax reform the family company will
end with him
why because the company will have to be
sold to meet the tax bill the federal
government will hand his descendants
the company's already faced the death
tax multiple times in its history and
given millions
upon millions to the federal government
this next death tax bill
will be the death blow mr president i'm
proud
that republicans improve the death tax
situation for a lot of family farms and
businesses
by passing estate tax reform in the tax
cuts and jobs act
but doubling the exemption is not enough
there are still family farms and
businesses out there that aren't
protected from this tax
and in my view losing even one family
farm or ranch or
business to the death tax is one too
many
not to mention the fact that in less
than five years the expanded exemption
will
expire putting many farms and businesses
back
in the taxes crosshairs family farms and
businesses play a vital role in the
economy and in communities
family farms and ranches are the
lifeblood literally
of rural communities in south dakota
they're a source of jobs they provide
support for local businesses they help
build up
local schools and local infrastructure
losing
a local farm can hit rural communities
very hard
mr president is mind-boggling that the
federal government
imposes a tax that punishes all the
things
we should be encouraging the death tax
punishes hard work
it punishes success it punishes
innovation
success should not be a dirty word
and families and employees should not be
punished because a family has worked
hard and built up
a successful farm or ranch or business
on top of all this the death tax is an
inefficient
tax that raises a small amount of
revenue while placing a very large
burden
on farmers and ranchers and small
businessmen and women
this president repealing the death tax
is an idea that has won bipartisan
support in the past including including
support for more than one sitting
democrat senator i hope it will win
bipartisan support
in this congress as well and i will
continue
to fight to ensure that no family farm
or business has to worry
about this punishing tax i said it
before and i'll say it again
one family farm or business lost
is one too many mr president i yield the
floor and i suggest the absence of a
quorum
the clerk will call the roll this
baldwin
you
you
you
majority whip mr president i asked
quorum call be suspended without
objection
i asked to speak as if in morning
business also without objection
mr president it's flattering when the
republican senate leader comes to the
floor and mentions your name
and senator mcconnell did just that this
morning the issue was the filibuster
and senator mcconnell found a quote of
several years ago where i spoke in favor
of the filibuster to protect minority
rights in the senate
it's true i did say that and it was
based on
life experience having already served in
the senate for a number of years
i came to understand how it evolved
as one of the procedures of the senate
but i'll have to say to you that my
impression of the filibuster
changed and the reason it changed was
none other than the republican senate
majority
leader now minority leader senator
mcconnell
you see the filibuster really was
created in the senate through its own
rules as i explained yesterday
and it came to define the senate
in this respect the founding fathers
looked to the senate
to provide two representatives and
literally senators
from each state regardless of population
so smaller states in back in the
original colonies smaller
states like delaware would have the same
number of senators as a large state like
virginia
and that was their intention so the
protection of minority rights was kind
of built into the definition of the
united states senate
and the filibuster became its
manifestation in the procedure the daily
procedure of the senate
and under that filibuster of course one
senator could
stop the debate or at least slow it down
by
insisting on a filibuster
only to be stopped by a an extraordinary
majority of the senate voting
to return to the regular business that
was the case
in 1957 because in august of 1957
senator strom thurman took to the floor
of this
united states senate and initiated the
longest filibuster in its history
24 hours and 18 minutes the man stood
by his desk and spoke without stopping
he didn't have any permission to leave
the floor for any reason and
certainly couldn't sit down without
losing his filibuster
he did it he did it for the wrong reason
i'm afraid because he was trying to stop
the march of
civil rights in this country but he did
it determined he achieved that goal
and when he did in 1957
that was the fifth filibuster in the
history
of the senate in the previous five
decades in other words if you went back
to
1919 all the way to 1957
strom thurmans was the fifth filibuster
in history
once every decade a filibuster emerged
on the senate floor
well that world has changed dramatically
changed
we can now have five filibusters in a
couple weeks
we now have on average 80 filibusters a
year
because of the urging and direction of
the senator from kentucky senator
mcconnell
he has institutionalized the filibuster
to the point where it
is now the normal course of business not
an extraordinary procedure
i recounted the fact that i introduced
the dream act 20 years ago
20 years ago durbin what kind of senator
are you
that in 20 years you can't pass the
dream act
well i brought it to the senate floor on
five different occasions and on five
different occasions it was stopped by
the filibuster
other members can tell the story of
their legislative experience on the
floor too
the point i'm getting to is this it
wasn't until
senator mcconnell and the republicans
who follow him
decided to make the filibuster just
daily business in the senate
that it was abused to the point where
the senate stopped doing
regular legislative business i'd like
senator mcconnell to come to the floor
of the next opportunity he has
and explain this to me in the last
calendar
year 2020 the senate
considered 29 amendments on the floor of
the senate in the entire
year now that doesn't count vodarama
which is an aberration that i don't
think
would ever be accused of being
deliberative but
29 regular order amendments
during the course of a year embarrassing
isn't it when you think of this great
so-called debating society
29 times we brought an amendment to the
floor
well it was an improvement an
improvement
over the previous year 30 percent
improvement in fact
because in the year 2019 under senator
mcconnell's leadership
we had 22 amendments so
when senator mcconnell and others come
to the floor
and plead for us to hang on to to the
traditions of the senate
i would tell you that their
interpretation of the traditions
is strangling this body they have beaten
the old filibuster to the point where
it is hardly recognizable and is now
regular order of business
in the united states senate and that's
why many of us
frustrated with having worked so hard to
come here
wanting to do the best we can to
represent the people who've sent us here
are so frustrated by the current state
of procedure
and for senator mcconnell and other
republicans to come to the floor and
plead for hanging on
to this tradition is actually pleading
for the senate to continue to do
less and less each year there are those
of us now in control
on the majority side bare majority side
on the democratic side
who really believe there's much more to
be done in the senate the american
people expect us to respond
now you might ask well how did you pass
the american rescue plan
if there's a filibuster used so
frequently
it was under a process called
reconciliation which depends on a
majority vote
you can't filibuster under the
reconciliation that's why
this amazing bill this new law
the american rescue plan by president
biden is so sweeping in its reach
we had to try to combine under this law
so many provisions that have been
affected by the pandemic
and the state of the economy because we
knew that returning to the regular order
of business
with the filibuster looming every single
day would tie our hands
just as sure as we've seen in the past
several years
so senator mcconnell thank you for
mentioning my name
but if i became skeptical of the
filibuster it's because of your use of
it
and i hope that you understand that you
can't have it both ways
it can't be a rare procedure and be
a procedure that dominates the actual
business of the senate as this has done
for so many years
mr president i ask it by following your
remarks be placed to the separate
partner record
without objection last year i came to
the floor on multiple occasions to ask
consent for a simple sensible resolution
it called for the united states to
cooperate in global efforts to address
the covet pandemic
at the time that point was obvious and
it's even more obvious today
pandemics don't respect borders
none of us are safe from highly
infectious diseases until
all of us are safe that's especially
important
to keep in mind as we begin to turn a
corner here in america
last week during his first address to
the nation
president biden announced that all
adults in america over the age of 18
will be eligible for vaccinations on may
1st of this year
if all goes to plan we can look forward
as president biden mentioned to a fourth
of july with family
and close friends at a close distance
considering what they inherited the
biden administration deserves
credit for dramatically scaling up
vaccinations in america the
administration helped
to strike an historic partnership
between rival drug makers
ramped up manufacturers of vaccine and
in pre-improved coordination with state
officials everywhere
we're seeing the world of difference
that this makes
when you put competent qualified
leadership
in charge in the white house and in
state capitals good things happen our
weekly vaccine shipments in illinois
have nearly doubled
the federal government has erected a
mass vaccination site at the united
center in chicago
and it's also supported partnerships
with community health centers
and retail pharmacies to expand access
to vaccines
a cautious hopefulism hopefulness rather
is washing over america but we can't
lose momentum in our fight against covet
to put this pandemic really behind us
and to bury it in history
we need to lend a hand to the many poor
nations
that have yet to receive a single dose
of vaccine
the inequities are stark 10 countries
have accounted for 75 percent of total
vaccinations administered worldwide
while approximately 100 countries have
yet to administer
any vaccine dosage this dangerous
shortfall has the potential to undermine
the good work
that's happening here in america closing
this gap
is not only the right and moral thing to
do it's the safest and smartest things
to do
to stop the threat cova and its
increasingly
contagious variants posed to us all
remember back a little over a year ago
an obscure city in china generated
a virus we think they did that ended up
circling the world many times over and
changing life on this planet
last month i received a briefing from dr
fauci
on the new genetic mutations at cove 19.
he shared troubling news about variants
that are emerging in the united kingdom
south africa and brazil some of them may
have more
resistance to our current vaccines than
we care to
see he warned that if we fail to stamp
out the virus
globally then we will continue to see
risks within our own borders variants of
the virus
could counteract the tremendous progress
we've made
and the progress that we're poised to
make in the near future
as i said outside viruses don't
recognize borders crushing the virus in
other countries
is a strategic investment in our own
national safety and security president
biden understands this
he's serious about addressing the virus
first in america
and then around the world he has set us
on a pace to vaccinate
all eligible americans over the course
of next several months
and let me urge those who are hesitant
or
skeptical as to whether it's the right
thing to do do it
please for yourself for those you love
and for this nation
president biden wisely halted president
trump's withdrawal from the world health
organization
he joined the global kovacs vaccine
effort
and he allocated significant funding
toward global vaccination efforts
funding that is expanded under the
american rescue plan
which we passed just a few weeks ago
here in the senate
secretary treasury janet yellen recently
announced that the united states will
support the issuance
of special drawing rights a type of imf
foreign exchange reserve that can help
poor countries
buy vaccines and whether the economic
fallout from pandemic
a welcome move that i encouraged and
was a co-author of with senator sanders
and
congressman chewie garcia just last week
the president announced a partnership
with key allies in the pacific region
to provide at least one billion coveted
vaccines to countries in asia
this is prescient global leadership
long overdue the president's actions
will save lives here
at home and abroad and these investments
will fuel a global
economic recovery which we all want to
see
to understand why a global strategy has
called for look at history
some of you who are witnessing this
statement on the floor
at home may be old enough to have a
distinct
circular scar on your upper arm
maybe you've seen it on the arms of a
parent or grandparent
that mark is a relic from one of the
world's greatest public health victories
the eradication of the deadly smallpox
virus
the fact that so few people to living
today remember the death and misery
caused by that disease
is a testament to global public health
strategy that stopped it
smallpox was one of the most devastating
diseases to afflict mankind
it is estimated to have killed up to 300
million people in the 20th century
500 million people in the last 100 years
in 1967 the world health organization
launched an historic
international effortlessly eradicated
it was one of the most successful public
health initiatives in human history
next month marks the 41st anniversary of
that historic achievement
in the years since america has led
similar global efforts to stamp out
diseases
like polio and ebola if we follow in
these footsteps historians will one day
add covid
to the top of that list of historic
achievements pursuing a global strategy
is the most effective way may be the
only way
to accelerate vaccine production and
distribution every corner of the world
by sharing our wealth of knowledge and
resources with the world
we reap life-saving benefits not just
around the world but right here at home
we all know public health is bigger than
partisan partisanship and always has
been
in the 2000s for example i called on
then president bush
to help stem the scourge of aids around
the world through the historic pepfar
program
at the time many of my republican
friends in the senate supported it
i hope and expect that they'll do the
same when it comes to addressing
the global effort against covet 19.
the moment calls for nothing less public
health experts
understand that president biden
understands i know we here in congress
understand that we can end the threat of
covet once and for all
it's within our power i asked consent mr
president that
the next statement i may be may put in a
separate part of the record
without objection mr president let me
start this statement by saying i'm a fan
of the u.s postal service
i have been throughout my life i believe
the men and women who make the postal
service work
do a great service to this country and
distinguish us from many countries in
the world
which don't have anything near our
service
or reliability in delivering the mail
having said that and believe it to my
inner being
the postal service needs to take a hard
look at what's going on
within their ranks today last month's
the u.s postal service great lakes area
sent out a postal equivalent of an sos
it put out a call to mail carriers in
five surrounding states
asking for letter carriers to come to my
state of illinois
and help deliver a huge backlog of
undelivered packages and envelopes
it pleaded for mail carriers in the five
color counties surrounding chicago
to help deliver chicago's chicago's mail
on sundays
ken labay is one of the mail carriers
who answered that call for help
mr lebe has been a mail carrier in
suburban mount prospect illinois
just outside chicago for 28 years
he's a president of the local letter
carriers union
he's also quite an athlete in 2002 he
was the only
mail carrier on the usps sponsored
professional cycling team
he volunteered for the last sunday in
february
he figured he had the knowledge and
endurance to help reduce the male
backlogs that had plays
plagued the postal service in chicago
what he discovered
he said stunned him at every home he
delivered to
he stuffed 20 to 30 pieces of mail in
the mailbox
he worked 12 hours on that sunday from
6am to 6pm
sent up to sundown without a break even
for lunch
still he couldn't complete the assigned
workload
the sheer volume of backlogged mail was
too great
inside the local post office ken said he
found packages stacked
everywhere some appeared to have been
there for a month
or more the entire situation looked in
his words
like an episode of extreme hoarders
a crisis
chicago land is not the only postal
chaos
location mr president nearly
nine months after a new postmaster
general unveiled his surprise
reorganization plan postal service in
much of the nation is erratic
male delays are the longest they've been
in generations
according to the postal service's own
numbers the agency's delivery times
have shrunk to historic lows since the
new postmaster general
louis de joy took over last june at the
end of december
the agency had an on-time rate of 38
percent
for non-local mail what was it one year
earlier
92 percent 92 percent on time rate
descended to 38
under postmaster general de joy
before louis de joy took over 91 percent
of postal service customers gave usps
high marks one of the highest approval
ratings of any government agency
today postal customers across america
certainly in my state of illinois wait
anxiously for important checks and bills
that arrive weeks late
if at all they check tracking
websites to search for delayed packages
only to read that the package is quote
out for delivery in some neighborhoods
in chicago
residents have given up hope of
receiving mail at home
they stand in line for hours at the
local post office
to try to retrieve their mail themselves
often
even that doesn't work tracy otis is one
of those people
one day last month she was one of 40
customers
40 waiting line at the postal service
station in the gresham neighborhood
on the south side of chicago miss otis
hadn't had regular mail delivery since
christmas
she waited in line for hours hoping to
retrieve
a package of diabetic test strips before
her current supply ran out
she told a chicago sun times reporter
that she would volunteer to sort the
mail if it would help
she went home empty-handed that day
still not sure
where her package was or when if ever
she might see it
last month my staff in chicago estimated
there might be 300 pieces of mail
sitting undelivered in four chicago
postal facilities
we based that estimate on the number of
complaints we'd received in our office
soon after that the postal inspector
general released a report
that showed we were wrong there weren't
300 letters
in postal limbo in these facilities
there were 19
000 undelivered pieces of mail in those
four facilities
since then in my state the chaos has
stretched way beyond chicago
we hear from all over the state
springfield champaign urbana
belleville east st louis quincy peoria
the quad cities in rockford
these days in illinois and across
america we're seeing real hardship
for tens of millions of americans
waiting for mail delivery
patients and pharmacists complain about
late medication
people are getting dinged for late
mortgage and utility payments
and forced to pay late fees insurance
policies are being canceled because of
late payments
small business owners are forced to wait
weeks or months for payments
others are flooded with calls and emails
from customers wondering where the
packages are
a good way to lose business who
is louis de joy the mastermind of this
mess
did he come through the ranks of the
postal service like four postmaster
generals before him
no his qualifications he's a former
logistics executive who donated millions
of dollars to donald trump and the
republicans
no experience working at the postal
service before
donald trump tapped him to head this
agency last june
one month later in the middle of a
pandemic that turned postal deliveries
into a lifeline for many
mr dejoy unveiled a radical plan
to reorganize the postal service after
only one month in the job and no
experience in the department
he slashed overtime hours prohibited
late and extra mail delivery trips
and set stricter delivery schedules in
august with no
public explanation the postal service
began removing
mail sorting machines from postal
facilities around the country
reducing their ability to process mail
amazingly the postal service inspector
general determined that the changes were
ordered with no
analysis and no understanding of how
they might affect the timeliness of mail
delivery
a federal lawsuit forced the agency to
put
the changes on hold until after the
election
on february 6 mr dejoy was quoted in the
washington post saying that his new plan
for reorganizing the postal service
would be ready for public release
quote as early as next week he said that
on february 6
we're still waiting for it waiting for
the dejoy plan to shape up the
postal service it's like waiting for a
lost package
we know some of the biggest changes mr
dejoy joy intends to propose
because he's confirmed them publicly the
dejoy
plan for shaping up the post office is
expected to call for the following
service cuts higher prices and slower
mail delivery if that sounds like a
winning combination to you
i have some vintage computers to sell to
your business
in short this is not a solution this is
a sabotage of essential public service
and we shouldn't tolerate it well
america has a new president
who understands that affordable
efficient postal service
is essential to america five days after
taking off as president biden replaced
the chair
of the postal regulatory commission late
last month he filled three vacancies on
the postal service board of governors
the body that hires the postal
postmaster general
and oversees the postal service i
encourage president biden to make all
the changes necessary to rescue the
postal service
mr dejoy has offered a stream of excuses
for the chaos that has fallen the
postal service since he showed up he
says it's the pandemic
the christmas holidays bad weather
racial justice protest
an election he's got a list as long as
you're armed
i would remind him that in 1864 we held
a national election in the middle of a
civil war
and 150 000 union army troops voted
absentee
from the field the postal service is as
old as america itself
it has proven that it can adapt the
crisis with the right
leadership if mr dejoy cannot or will
not provide that leadership
i respectfully suggest he stepped down
i yield the floor
clerk will call the rule this baldwin
mr president senator from minnesota
mr president i ask that the quorum call
be vitiated without objection
mr president today i rise in support of
isabel guzman currently the director
of the presiding officers in california
office of the
small business advocate to be the
administer of the u.s
small business administration we all
know the importance of small businesses
and how they have been hit so hard
during
this pandemic small businesses employ
nearly
half of all private sector workers and
make outsized contributions to the
innovation
uh that makes america's economy strong
yet the coronavirus has put millions of
people
out of business hundreds of thousands of
these mom-and-pop brick and mortar
retail
shops out of business restaurants out of
business
and we are so pleased that there
is as we say in minnesota a lighthouse
that we're looking to
now i was up in duluth on sunday
and instead of the light at the end of
the tunnel which so many of us talk
about with the end of this pandemic the
mayor there referred to it
as a lighthouse they've got a lot of
lighthouses on lake superior
mr president and the end of this
pandemic is our lighthouse
and we see the blinking lights from a
distance but we know we are not
there yet and to get there we not only
need to get this vaccine to
every person and president has said we
will have available vaccines
uh by the end of may for every adult in
america we have to get it distributed
and our pandemic bill certainly uh is
going to be a major step toward getting
that done
but we also get need to get our business
economy back in order we need to be able
to
um not be so far down in the ground that
we can't climb out of where we are
and that's why having ms guzman who
served as deputy chief of staff and as
the senior advisor at the small business
administration
during the obama administration having
someone with her
record and her ability to lead in place
is so important she will oversee the
paycheck protection program
which we established on a bipartisan
basis in march of 2020
as part of the cares act as she
understands the need for greater equity
in loan distribution and has shown
commitment
to transparency and accurate loan
data she has made clear that she will
make the
paycheck protection program more
accessible to businesses
that have traditionally not had the
access to banking relationships
needed to secure loans and grants and
very significantly to me
and to those of us that worked on the
save our stages bill including
senator cornyn of texas who led the bill
with me
she has made clear that she will move on
the grant program
immediately we have been working with
the staff there
and we have made some uh gave given
these venues who have been shuttered the
first to
close the last to reopen the ability to
access ppp loans
which is really important right now but
we also want to get the grant
program out immediately get that money
out distributing over 16 billion
in grants our venues can't wait uh they
need that relief
and ms guzman will be key to leading our
way out of this and helping
um senator schumer with his
theaters in new york to the fargo
theater
in north dakota um we need to get this
done
a restaurant relief we just passed as
part of the
american rescue plan ager major
bill the 28.6 billion restaurant
revitalization fund
which is going to be so key when i was
at
the block food and drink restaurant in
st louis park on sunday
and then headed up duluth to the boat
club
with the mayor and the owners of the
boat club the stories i heard of servers
who've been laid off then came back laid
off and came back the stories i've
heard about the owners of some of these
restaurants taking out
repeated loans they are hanging in there
and we need to have
their backs one out of six restaurants
in this country has permanently closed
down
during the pandemic we don't want to
just go as the leader of the antitrust
subcommittee in the senate we don't want
to just
give all of our food service
and action in the restaurant area to the
big guys
we're pleased we have successful
restaurant chains in this country
but that can't be the only thing we have
and that's why
helping these smaller venues is so
important and ms guzman
gets that she is a lifelong
proponent of small businesses the
daughter of a small business owner
and as a former entrepreneur um this
makes her the right person
for this job at the pivotal time in the
life of our country she has the backing
of the u.s chamber of commerce
and numerous trade organizations i know
her leadership
at the sba will put our struggling
businesses
in the best hand with that mr president
i ask my colleagues to support the
nomination
of isabel guzman to be administrator of
the small business administration
you must be proud mr president as having
someone who has done such good work in
california in this job
we're excited about her and what she can
do and i also will put a
uh remarks on the record as i'm running
out of time i see my colleague from
wisconsin is here
um put and we're going to have the vote
ahead of us
um put my uh statement on the record
for javier becerra we're very excited
about him as well
to be the secretary of health and human
services
thank you uh mr president i yield the
floor
without objection i note the absence of
a quorum clerk will call the roll
ms baldwin
you
you
mr president obvious consent that the
quorum call be dispensed with
without objection i would ask consent
that i'd be permitted to finish my
remarks before the vote
also without objection thank you mr
president i rise today to voice my
strong support for isabel guzman's
nomination to serve as administrator of
the small business administration
our nation passed the one year mark of
covet 19 being declared a national
emergency
last saturday march 13th and thankfully
the american people can now see the
light
at the end of the tunnel already more
than 20 percent of all americans have
received at least one
covet 19 vaccine dose with an average of
more than 2.39 million additional doses
being administered each day we can see
the light at the end of the tunnel
but we are not there yet the covet 19
pandemic
has decimated american small businesses
and worst effects have been felt by the
most vulnerable small businesses
especially those
in black latino native and rural
communities
so sba must continue to be a lifeline in
the coming
months that's why it's important that we
confirm ms guzman's nomination
so she can provide the permanent steady
leadership sba
needs right now we when we pass the
cares act
congress test sba will won the most
important aspects
of covet 19 relief effort we knew we had
to support our small businesses
because the public health restrictions
on public gatherings
which have saved thousands of lives and
kept our communities safe
have been especially challenging for
small businesses
we had to help small businesses so that
we can get out of this pandemic
when our economy returns our small
businesses emerge
in a position to help our economy
recover and continue to grow
the cares act included 377 billion
dollars
in funds for small businesses and
created the paycheck protection program
the idle advance program and the small
business debt relief program to help
small businesses
that had traditional sba loans like 7a
and 504
then in april we passed legislation to
replenish the ppp
and idol and idle advanced grant program
with 370
billion dollars in additional funds in
december we passed
the bipartisan economic aid act to
provide another 325 billion dollars
to support small businesses allow for a
second round of ppp loans
and created the shutter venue operators
grant program
mr president in total last year congress
appropriated more than one
trillion dollars to the sba for covet 19
relief programs
since the passage of the cares act sba
has approved more than 7.5
million ppp loans worth more than 687
billion dollars
and more than 3.7 billion dollar idle
loans
worth more than 200 billion dollars
these loans and grants have saved
millions of jobs
and prevented millions of small
businesses from closing their doors
i want to thank the sba personnel who
have worked long hours including
nights and weekends to implement these
critical programs
sba still has a lot of work left to do
as i mentioned the december bill created
the shuttered venue operators grant
program which we expect the
sba to open in the coming weeks sba has
also
opened a new 20 well cspa also has to
open
a new 28.6 billion dollar grant program
for restaurant bars which was created by
the historic american
rescue plan the plan appropriated an
additional 50 billion dollars in
economic relief for small businesses
including 15 billion dollars to targeted
idol advance grants
an additional 7.25 billion dollars to
ppp
and a 1.25 billion dollars for shuttered
venue grants
the plan also required sba to launch a
community navigator pilot program which
is designed to help small businesses in
underserved
and underbanked communities access to
covet 19 relief
resources available to them these
programs will be key to our economic
recovery recovery that brings me to mrs
guzman's nomination
mrs guzman has decades of experience
working with supporting and
found founding small businesses which
have
which he has prepared to lead the sba
during this moment
most recently mrs guzman was the state
of california's director of the office
of small business advocate
where she oversaw implementation of the
state covet 19
relief grant program mrs gutmann also
helped lead sba during the obama
administration serving as the deputy
chief of staff and senior advisor
for three years from 2014 through 2017.
during her nomination hearing last month
mrs guzman demonstrated her commitment
to ensuring the sba relief programs
as well as its traditional loan programs
are implemented equitably and they will
help small businesses and black latino
native rural and other underserved
communities overcome
the historic barriers they face she is
committed to ensuring the agency has the
right systems
technology and operating procedures in
place
to advance the mission and reach all of
our small businesses
and she's committed to ensure funds get
into the hands of small businesses have
been hurt the most
by the pandemic and the economic crisis
through no fault of their own
mr president as we learned during the
pandemic sba has a key role to play in
our nation's effort to fight systems of
inequality
that prevent many entrepreneurs and
underserved and underbanked communities
from starting and growing successful
businesses
mrs guzman will be an advocate for small
businesses in these communities
within the administration and she will
be a strong partner to
us in congress as we build federal
capacity to support
small businesses through the coming
economic recovery
mrs guzman's commitment to equity and
her deep knowledge and the needs of
small businesses
and the best policies to help them are
why she received bipartisan praise
during her nomination hearing
and was advanced by the committee by a
bipartisan vote
mrs guzman has earned broad support from
the
small business community her nomination
has been endorsed by the u.s
chamber of commerce u.s hispanic chamber
the u.s black chamber the national small
business association the small business
majority
the national federation of independent
businesses and many other small business
advocacy groups
sba needs an administrator who can hit
the ground running and i'm confident mrs
guzman is exactly the right person for
the job
i urge my colleagues who have spoken
with small business owners who still
need
support from the sba and i'm sure
everyone has to join me and vote to
confirm mrs guzman
as the sba administer administrator with
that mr president i would deal the floor
the clerk will report the motion to
invoke cloture
cloture motion we the undersigned
senators in accordance with the
provisions of rule 22 of the standing
rules of the senate
do hereby move to bring to a close the
debate on the nomination of executive
calendar number 26
isabella castillas guzman of california
to be administrator of the small
business administration
signed by 17 senators by unanimous
consent the mandatory quorum call has
been waived the question is
is it the sense of the senate that
debate on the nomination
of isabella casillas guzman of
california
to be administrator of the small
business administration
shall be brought to a close the yeas and
a's are mandatory under the rule the
clerk will call the roll
ms baldwin
mr brasso mr bennett
mrs blackburn
mr blumenthal
mr blunt mr booker
mr boseman
mr brawn mr brown
mr burr
ms canthal
mrs capito mr cardin
mr carper mr casey
mr cassidy
miss collins
mr coons
mr cornyn
miss cortes masto
mr cotton
mr kramer mr crapo
mr cruz
mr james
ms duckworth mr durbin
ms ernst mrs feinstein
mrs fisher mrs gillibrand
mr graham mr grassley
haggerty
miss hassan
mr hawley
mr heinrich
mr hickenlooper
ms hirono
mr hoeven
mrs todd smith
mr inhofe mr johnson
mr kane
mr kelly
mr kennedy mr king
miss klobuchar
mr lankford
mr leahy
mr lee
mr lujan
miss loves
mr mansion mr markey
mr marshall
mr mcconnell
mr menendez
mr merkley
mr moran ms murkowski
mr murphy
mrs murray mr ossoff
mr padilla
mr paul
mr peters
mr portman
mr reed
mr romney miss rosen
mr rounds mr rubio
mr sanders mr sass
mr schatz
mr schumer
mr scott of florida mr scott of south
carolina
mrs shaheen
mr shelby
miss cinema
miss smith miss davenau
mr sullivan
mr tester
mr thune
mr tillis
mr toomey mr tuberville
mr van hollen
mr warner mr warnock
ms warren mr whitehouse
mr wicker mr wyden
mr young
senator voting in the affirmative
baldwin
brown cantwell
cardin
carper cassidy
durbin
fisher gillibrand hassan
kelly king lankford lujan
marky menendez
murkowski hounds shots
mr whitehouse mr whitehouse ah
mr tester mr tester i
mr risch mr rish no
mr van hollen mr van hollen
mrs blackburn mrs blackburn no
mr shelby mr shelby no
mr wyden mr wyden aye
mr hawley mr hawley no
mr soon mr thune ah
mr cotton mr cotton no
miss collins miss collins ah
mr sanders mr sanders
miss ernst miss ernst ah mrs feinstein
mrs feinstein
mrs capito mrs capitol i
mr brasso mr barrasso aye
mrs murray mrs murray aye mr booker mr
booker
aye
mr marshall mr marshall ah
mr scott mr scott of south carolina no
mr burr mr burr aye
mr schumer mr schumer ah
mr cruz mr cruz no
mr graham mr graham aye
mr blunt mr blunt ah
mr grassley mr grassley
mr romney mr romney
mr twomey mr toomey mr warnock mr
warnock
mr boseman mr boseman no mr sass
mr sass no mr coons mr coons
i
mr paul mr paul aye
mr brawn mr braun
no
you
mr johnson mr johnson aye
mr sullivan mr sullivan aye
mr lee mr lee no
mr rubio mr rubio no
mrs hyde smith mrs hyde smith aye
you
mr mcconnell mr mcconnell
i
mr bennett mr bennett ah
mr kramer mr kramer i'm miss cortez
masto miss cortez masto
aye mr hovind mr hoeven aye
[Music]
john
mr young mr young
[Music]
mr murphy mr murphy
mr moran mr moran i
mr portman mr portman
you
the yeas are 80 the knees are 18.
the motion is agreed to
senator from delaware consent that all
post closure time on gusman nomination
be considered expired at 2 30 pm today
without objection uh mr president i have
six requests for committees to meet
during today's session of the senate
they have the approval of both majority
and minority leaders
duly noted thank you mr president
under the previous order the senate
stands at recess
until 2 15.
you